bonjour à tous en attendant qu eric
woerth nous rejoignent puisqu'il est en
train d'écouter les propositions et le
plan économie présenté par françois
hollande
nous allons commencer avec guillaume ce
point presse sous forme de binôme la
semaine dernière ceux qui étaient là
nous avait trouvé à quatre les quatre
nouveaux porte parole
et comme on vous l'avait évoqué et bien
nous fonctionnerons par binôme tournant
est donc aujourd'hui avec guillaume un
point de l'actualité et avant que
guillaume larrivé fasse le tour j'allais
dire de nos propositions et un état des
lieux sur la politique en matière
d'immigration
je voudrais si vous voulez bien faire un
point sur différents évènements qui ont
lieu durant ce week-end qui ont eu lieu
durant ce week-end
d'abord évidemment une pensée pour le
peuple burkinabé suite à l'attentât
terroriste qu'ils ont subis et bien sûr
condamné à nouveau cet acte de barbarie
et une pensée particulière pour nos
trois compatriotes qui ont trouvé la
mort à cette occasion l'actualité par
ailleurs de ce week-end nous aura pour
le moins fait sourire et ça n'aura pas
d'ailleurs échappé à guillaume larrivé
lorsqu'il le commentait les voeux du
président de la république à tulle
comment ne pas être étonné de nous
allons dire ce dysfonctionnement cette
dichotomie d'un président de la
république qui va présenter des voeux
pour inaugurer une salle de cinéma dont
l'année dernière nous avions eu droit à
la pose de la première pierre un vrai
décalage par rapport à une actualité
évidemment je le rappelais
particulièrement dramatique dans un
environnement socio économique et
mondiale qui faisait que là on se
demandait en effet si c'était vraiment
le président de la république française
qui étaient mobilisés et qui était sur
le front
nous avons par ailleurs et vous l'aurez
constaté droit aux
en bazar au gouvernement un véritable
grand bazar car tout y est possible
maintenant un ministre qui veut partir
une ministre qui devait partir mais qui
ne part pas et on assiste là à une
incohérence à une incohérence dont le
président hollande est seule responsable
une incohérence d'une politique
gouvernementale
une incohérence d'une manière de
gouverner une incohérence qui ne pourra
que contribuer à la désaffection des
français pour le politique et ça n'est
pas d'ailleurs l'étude qui est parue
dans le jdd du cevipof et qui rappellent
des chiffres lorsqu'on est élu qui nous
interpelle quand on voit que les
français sont 1 31%
lassé c'est la lassitude qui arrivent
comme au premier pour expliquer leur
leur état d'être
lorsque la morosité arrive à 29% ou
lorsque la méfiance est à 28 % et c'est
donc dans ce climat que nous avons par
ailleurs une france qui est en
déliquescence et nous reviendrons tout à
l'heure sur ce xxi ème plan proposé par
françois hollande en matière économique
qui ne peut être en rien la réponse tant
attendue
le problème c'est que nous en sommes en
effet à un xxi ème plan quand il y avait
une telle urgence et que comme le
rappelait également guillaume ce matin
c'est une insulte qui est faite aux
chômeurs tels que ça nous est présenté
parallèlement comment aussi ne pas
s'étonner que la situation française
international et citant est temps si
dramatique que là aussi on ne semble pas
une véritable mobilisation du
gouvernement au niveau même européen de
mesures à prendre par rapport à cette
guerre contre le terrorisme
enfin je voudrais vous citer une phrase
et c'est plutôt une interrogation
lorsque je parlais d'un cohérence
gouvernementale
quelqu'un a dit il ya quelques temps
depuis 12 mois 24 des 28 pays européens
ont baissé
le chômage nous sommes dans les quatre
qui n'ont pas réussi à le faire
notre économie est celle d'une société
bloquée on n'a pas tout fait pour
l'emploi qui a dit cette phrase là
emmanuel macron le 7 janvier dans son
interview du monde alors s'il faut faire
preuve un moment de cohérence
eh bien je pense que là haut tu
oublieras n'a pas fait preuve je pense
que peut-être monsieur macro lui fera
preuve de cohérence
c'était un petit point sur l'actualité
du week end je voudrais par ailleurs
vous donner des informations sur la vie
de notre mouvement
concernant l'agenda en dehors donc du
bureau politique qui se tiendra cette
semaine mardi à 17h30 à huis clos le
président de notre mouvement se rendre à
une cérémonie de voeux de la fédération
des républicains du gard à nîmes
ce déplacement est donc un déplacement
qui était prévu initialement
il sera suivi d'une séquence terrain est
par ailleurs le président continuera à
faire les déplacements que nous avions
évoqué la semaine dernière de manière
plus calme et tranquille un à deux par
semaine puis nous aurons mardi mercredi
20 à 19h15 un nouveau grand rendez vous
du projet des républicains sur le thème
quelle organisation territoriale pour la
santé à l'initiative d'eric woerth avec
différents participants dont vous
trouverez le nom sur l'agenda qui vous
est remis et puis je voudrais aussi vous
faire part de différentes nominations
le président dont des républicains
nicolas sarkozy a nommé marc philippe
daubresse conseiller politique
en outre sont nommés huit délégués
généraux chargés de l'animation de paul
de la réflexion pour l'élaboration du
projet pierre lellouche affaires
internationales claude greff affaires
sociales annie genevard éducation
philippe meunier défense catherine trong
le famille et société
christian saint-etienne économie mots
devant toi environnement david lisnard
culture par ailleurs un délégué général
en charge du numérique sera nommé dans
les prochains jours je vais donc
maintenant passer la parole à guillaume
qui va vous faire un point sur la
politique d'immigration sur la politique
d'immigration sur la non politique
d'immigration d'ailleurs puisque les
derniers chiffres de l'immigration
démontre que la france connaît
aujourd'hui un véritable chaos
migratoire rien et gérer rien n'est
maîtrisé et donc si vous le permettez je
vais évoquer devant vous cinq problèmes
qu'il faut regarder en face avant de
présenter au nom des républicains des
propositions très forte d'actions
immédiates que nous appelons le
gouvernement à mettre en oeuvre dès 2016
pour réduire significativement les flux
d'immigration vers la france cinq
problèmes
premier problème c'est que il ya eu en
2015 plus d'un million de franchissement
illégaux des frontières extérieures de
l'europe avec en réalité 0 contrôle
effectif les autorités européennes
indiqué il ya quelques jours que
seulement 23 % des personnes entrant
dans l'europe faisait l'objet de prise
d'empreintes qui veut dire que dans plus
de trois quarts des cas il ya zéro
contrôle 0 criblage 0 vérifications dans
des fichiers de police
ce qui veut bien dire que le contrôle
des frontières extérieures de l'europe
est aujourd'hui une fiction ça n'existe
pas premier problème deuxième
problème la france continue le
gouvernement français continue à
organiser une immigration légale massive
quelques chiffres qui sont pas encore
apparues dans le débat public en 2015 3
millions 197 1505 visas ont été délivrés
par le gouvernement français ça
représente une augmentation de + 39 25 %
par rapport à 2012
c'est absolument considérable il ya eu
parallèlement en 2015 212 1365 carte de
séjour délivrés par les préfets c'est
une hausse de 10% par rapport à 2012
dont 90000 pour des motifs de
rapprochement familial c'est à dire pas
pour des motifs de travail alors même
que dans le même temps le taux de
chômage en france et nous en parlerons
tout à l'heure atteint hélas un record
et que 43% des personnes immigrées en
âge actif sont sans emploi en france
nous apprend le cd et après d'un immigré
sur deux en âge actif qui aujourd'hui
sans emploi
troisième problème qu'il faut regarder
en face l'augmentation du nombre de
demandeurs d'asile vers la france en
2015 c'est + 22 % par rapport à 2014
c'est certes moins qu'en allemagne nous
le savons puisque le blocage du marché
du travail en france fait que on voit
bien que les demandeurs d'asile cherche
d'abord à aller vers l'allemagne plutôt
qu'en france mais quand même + 22 % en
france le système d'asile est plus que
jamais une machine à fabriquer des
clandestins quatrième problème seulement
1300 étrangers en situation illégale ont
été raccompagnés dans leurs pays
ce qui veut dire mécaniquement que le
nombre de clandestins présents en france
ne cesse d'augmenter
par l'effet des déboutés du droit
d'asile qui ne sont pas raccompagner à
la frontière par les faits aussi des
migrants ayant un visage de moins de
trois mois qui se maintiennent ensuite
illégalement en france
et quand ça augmentait comme je vous le
disais dans les proportions que j'évoque
les on voit bien que le nombre de
clandestins aussi augmentent en france
fortement cinquième et dernier problème
et c'est une annonce que je vous fais
car je crois que ce chiffre n'a pas été
communiqué quand on regarde de près les
statistiques de l'activité des services
de police et notamment ce qu'on appelle
l'état 4001
on constate en 2015 une diminution de
35% du nombre des infractions constatées
liés à l'immigration illégale
ce qui évidemment extrêmement paradoxal
au moment où la pression de
l'immigration clandestine augmente
l'activité policière liée à la lutte
contre l'immigration clandestine diminue
fortement
alors face à ce constat on veut regarder
en face nous faisons ici
cinq propositions immédiates pour sortir
de ce chaos migratoires et donc diminuer
fortement et 2016
l'immigration vers la france dans le
respect bien sûr de nos principes
d'humanité dans le respect des personnes
évidemment d'abord nous appelons nous
appelons françois hollande à organiser
au plus vite à paris une réunion de
crise avec la chancelière merkel et les
différents états européens pour
organiser de manière coordonnée
le rétablissement durable des contrôles
aux frontières intérieures organisée
deux manières coordonnait le
rétablissement durable des contrôles aux
frontières intérieures
parce qu'il ya aujourd'hui un certain
nombre d'initiatives nationales
provisoire notamment en autriche en
slovénie hongrie en suède au danemark en
norvège
nous pensons que la france doit rétablir
durablement ses contrôles aux frontières
intérieures après le 26 février qui est
la date
aujourd'hui retenu par le gouvernement
mais surtout il faut organiser tout cela
en concertation avec les autres pays
européens de manière coordonnée de
manière ordonnée
c'est le préalable indispensable à la
refondation de toutes les règles
européennes en matière d'entrée et de
séjour ce que nous appelons la
refondation de schengen
première proposition un appel au
président de la république pour
organiser rapidement cette réunion de
crise la france doit prendre
l'initiative
la france ne doit pas être à la remorque
des initiatives désordonnées dans
d'autres capitales européennes où à
bruxelles
nous devons prendre des initiatives
deuxième proposition que nous formons
ici au nom des républicains
il faut évidemment abroger immédiatement
la circulaire valse de novembre 2012 sur
la régularisation des clandestins
elle a en réalité créer une sorte de
droit à la régularisation c'est à dire
une prime à la clandestinité
nous ne voulons pas il faut l'abroger
troisième proposition comme vous le
savez donc dans quelques jours le
parlement va reprendre la discussion sur
un projet de loi relatif à l'immigration
ça passe en commission mercredi sa passe
dans l'hémicycle la semaine prochaine il
faut fixer dès 2016 en tout cas nous le
proposons des plafonds d'immigration
c'est à dire un contingent limitatif à
débattre au parlement pour tenir compte
de nos capacités d'accueil de nos
capacités de logement de l'état du
marché du travail nous y reviendrons
avec le secrétaire général eric woerth
qui sont évidemment très contrainte
quatrième proposition nous proposons de
faciliter les procédures de reconduite à
la frontière et d'expulsion des
clandestins pour ça il faut être très
concret il faut utiliser pleinement dans
le respect du droit dans le respect
naturellement un certain nombre de
contrôle juridictionnel
il faut utiliser pleinement les centres
de rétention administrative nous
proposons que la durée maximale de
rétention passe de 45 jours c'est le cas
aujourd'hui à 180 jours c'est-à-dire à
six mois nous rappelons que royaume-uni
ou aux pays bas
cette durée est illimitée et en
allemagne elle est de 18 ans elle est de
18 mois six mois c'est un délai
nécessaire pour organiser avec les pays
d'origine
les retours de leurs ressortissants et
obtenir notamment au plan technique les
laissez passer consulaires
indispensables à ces reconduites à la
frontière cinquième et dernière
proposition de ce plan d'action immédiat
que nous proposons pour sortir du chaos
migratoires il faut revoir les
conditions dans lesquelles les
étrangères en france accède aux
prestations sociales
un étranger qui exercent le même travail
et versé les mêmes cotisations
salariales qu'un français doit bien sûr
avoir accès à la même assurance sociale
pour le protéger des risques liés aux
accidents du travail à la maladie à la
vieillesse mais un étranger tout juste
arrivé en france n'a pas lui a bénéficié
de prestations sociales financées par
l'impôt de personnes qui résident en
france de longue date c'est pourquoi
nous proposons très concrètement de
restreindre l'accès aux allocations
familiales et au logement social en le
conditionnant à au moins cinq années de
résidence légale en france
cinq années de résidence légale en
france comme c'est d'ailleurs déjà le
cas pour le pour le
s toutes ces propositions nous les
mettons sur la table
certaines avaient déjà été exprimée
notamment au mois de septembre lorsque
président nicolas sarkozy avait fait
voter les adhérents de notre mouvement
sur un certain nombre de propositions
nous pensons que la dégradation des
chiffres de l'immigration
l'accélération de la pression migratoire
rend ces propositions encore plus
urgente et nous appelons le gouvernement
à entendre ces propositions que nous
allons aussi décliné dans les jours à
venir au parlement avec eric ciotti
notamment sous forme d'amendement
maintenant après cette introduction
cette sorte de mise en bouche
eric woerth qui regardaient très
attentivement le président de la
république s'exprimait va à son tour
vous dire ce qu'il pense de tout cela le
tout bien écouter bonjour donc j'ai
avons évidemment écouter le président
donc c'est des réactions à chaud et puis
on fera en sorte au fur et à mesure des
textes parce que tous appellent des
textes évidemment à commenter tout cela
je crois que le président il cherche le
pardon des offenses faites aux
entreprises et aux français depuis
maintenant deux ans et demi les chiffres
sont catastrophiques
le gouvernement a massacré l'économie
française la création d'emplois est
extrêmement faible regarder ce matin les
chiffres qui sont sortis chacun ils y
avaient accès en france où on crée
grosso modo neuf fois moins d'emplois
dans le secteur marchand
quand d'allemagne est beaucoup moins que
dans des pays qui ont dû affronter des
crises bien plus forte que nous
notamment l'espagne ou l'italie
c'est vrai aussi dans le domaine de
l'apprentissage
il ya un volet apprentissage dans ce que
dit le président de la république mais
c'est le pompier qui essayait d'éteindre
le feu qui a mis lui même
l'apprentissage a baissé en france dans
les années 2014 2013 et 2014 et frémit à
peine dans l'année 2015 plus de 11 pour
deux chutes de l'apprentissage en france
alors si c'est une priorité
on se demande réellement pourquoi ça n'a
pas été auparavant sur un sujet aussi
sensible et sur un sujet aussi
consensuel il ya une forme de rédemption
dans ce propos du président pour dire je
me suis beaucoup trompé donc je vais
maintenant beaucoup agir il ya urgence
probablement mais il ya urgence
depuis le début de son mandat et cette
urgence il est passé à côté et il a
aggravé la situation française la france
décroche elle décroche quasiment
aujourd'hui inexorablement les
propositions faites par le président de
la république ne sont évidemment pas
suffisant pour réduire ce décrochage
je vais prendre quelques exemples qui
montrent que s'il y a urgence
aujourd'hui il y avait évidemment
urgence hier on va de pacte en plan qui
se succèdent sans succès il suffit que
vous fassiez référence aux précédentes
déclarations notamment annuel du
président de la république tout se passe
toujours au mois de janvier
tout d'un coup on lance quelque chose
parce qu'on s'aperçoit que ça va mal et
donc on surjoue par rapport à l'année
précédente ont commencé il ya très vite
il ya donc très loin entre les
intentions et l'action il ya même un
fossé considérable dans l'ensemble de ce
quinquennat des entre les intentions et
l'action sur le plan lui-même sur ce
programme sur ce package
que peut-on dire à ce stade
d'abord en ce qui concerne les
formations 500000 formation l'annoncé a
déjà depuis quelques jours le président
de la république l'avait dit lors de ses
voeux c'est pas réaliste
tout le monde le sait est ce qu'on doit
faire des plans à coup de mesures irréel
20 questions
on est dans le concret est ce qu'on doit
mentir aux français systématiquement est
ce qu'on peut donner l'espoir aux
français qu' après une formation
délivrer rapidement ils retrouveront un
emploi
la vérité est que non 500000 formation
c'est quasiment multiplié par deux le
volume des formations qui sont
aujourd'hui délivrer par pôle emploi
avec bien des difficultés
donc on sait bien que la machine en
termes de formation française ne peut
pas suivre simplement parce qu'elle en a
pas les moyens
un formateur ne sont pas là les lieux de
formation ne sont pas là elle est
contenu des formations ne sont ne sont
pas là et c'est donc extrêmement
dangereux de commencer l'année par un
mensonge aux français qui est nous
allons former 500 mille personnes de
plus demandeurs d'emploi quand même ce
qu'il a dit d'abord avant c'est
d'ailleurs quasiment en doublant ses
capacités c'est donc un mensonge qui est
grave parce que il ne sera pas suivi de
réalité la durée des formations
président de la borde pas bhl c'est une
vraie question aujourd'hui la durée des
formations chez pôle emploi c'est de
l'ordre entre quatre et cinq mois ça ne
s'adresse pas nécessairement aux
personnes qui ont ce n'est pas suffisant
on pourrait bien que 4 à 5 mois ci à la
fois trop pour des personnes qui ont un
emploi et pas assez pour celles qui n'en
n'ont pas donc il faut là dessus
aller beaucoup plus loin il faut savoir
comment au delà des financements
comment les entreprises peuvent réagir
il faut trouver les lieux de deux
formations tout ça n'existe pas je pense
que le président s'est trompé non pas
d'un zéro mais enfin pas loin de ceux là
est la vérité aussi il faut quand même
que le président l'admettent c'est que
cinq cent mille personnes formées c'est
impossible mais si cinq cent mille
personnes formées il faut derrière qui
est cinq cent mille postes
car après la formation le jour d'après
la formation qu'est ce qui se passe si
la personne revient chez pôle emploi et
recommencent à pointer chez pôle emploi
et qui a pas de faim de deux
propositions claires dans bausch c'est
évidemment quelque chose qui accroît la
désespérance plutôt que ne recréent de
l'espoir et on voit bien que le jour
d'après il n'y a pas d'emploi le
président inverse les facteurs il veut
former sans emploi je pense qu'il faut
d'abord créer les conditions de la
croissance est évidemment en même temps
fort mais c'est pas du tout la même
chose ce qui fait que rien n'a été
abordée
clairement et sérieusement vie sur le
volet fiscal mis sur le volet social ni
en réalité sur l'ensemble des
problématiques du marché du travail même
si si je reviendrai donc des formations
sans emploi c'est pas du tout ce qui
peut être un objectif crédible réel
écrire de l'espoir pour l'ensemble de
nos concitoyens qui sont dans une phase
de désespérance on l'a vu dans le
sondage publié dimanche
donc des formations non réaliste et des
formations sans emploi sur
l'apprentissage président a beau jeu de
le dire d'enfin son gouvernement a
massacré l'apprentissage nous voyons
bien que c'est une filière d'avenir
c'est une filière d'excellence tout le
monde en est d'accord sauf que ça s'est
pas passé comme ça donc très bien
inversion des priorités recréer des
conditions propres à soutenir la
création de nouveaux apprentis
aujourd'hui l'apprentissage a baissé on
voit bien que les conditions de création
d'un apprentissage plus fort passe par
beaucoup de transformations le président
là dessus a été acier assez flou dont
acte
nous verrons une meilleure coopération
avec les régions où d'une manière
globale avec les collectivités locales
bien évidemment mais en tout cas il faut
régler notamment le problème de la durée
de l'apprentissage de la durée également
du temps passé dans l'entreprise de la
capacité à rompre les contrats
d'apprentissage donc la lourdeur des
contrats d'apprentissage du coup de
l'apprentissage pour les entreprises
tout ça n'a pas été abordée sur les les
aides aux entreprises
d'abord président a parlé de
normalisation de libérer un peu lente
reprise tant mieux il commence à
détricoter ce qu'il a lui-même tricoter
ils détricotent la loi pinel l'hôpital
elle a compliqué les choses pour les
auto-entrepreneurs président dit il faut
baisser
au fond les conditions où les obstacles
à l'accès à certaines professions mode
ou statues d'entrepreneuriat premiers à
les avoir compliqué cette précision de
la république lui même il n'a pas évoqué
la question de la pénibilité qui est une
question tout à fait considérable pour
les entreprises et qui est un facteur
majeur de complexité des choses même
s'il a évoqué le compte personnalisé
enfin le création d'emplois comme je le
disais tout à l'heure a été passée sous
silence
jamais on a aussi peut créer d'emplois
en france et ça il faut évidemment en
face qui est des raisons et qui est d en
tout cas des propositions qui n'ont pas
été faites et puis sur le code du
travail
tout ça à chaud le président renvoie au
rapport que doit délivrer monsieur
badinter dont peu de temps qui est
lui-même un rapport ce déjà le rapport
combrexelle capacité tout à fait
extraordinaire à faire des rapports sur
des rapports un jour font un moment
donné il faut un tout petit peu décidée
alors il ya des intentions dans le
domaine du code du travail
il faudra vérifier ce qu'il ya derrière
ses intentions en tout cas il a
l'intention de ne pas changer la durée
légale du travail ce qui était
probablement me semble-t-il une une
faute il faut évidemment faire évoluer
cette durée légale elle précisé y'a pas
de précisions dans ce domaine là un
deuxième sujet président parle des
charges sur les entreprises le cic eux
il indique qu'il transformera s'est
hissé en baisse de charges dont acte une
bonne chose
pourquoi avoir attendu autant de temps
lorsqu'on a eu ce débat sur le cic eux
nous avons l'opposition a proposé de
passer ici se tapent à un crédit d'impôt
mais que ce soit une baisse des charges
d'être durablement inscrits dans le
barème des charges sociales ça n'a pas
été le cas
il n'a pas souhaité pour des raisons
essentiellement d'économies pour faire
en sorte qu' on ne paye au fond que un
an après donc il a déjà repoussé d'un an
l'efficacité de cette baisse de charge
aujourd'hui il revient sur cette idée
quelle consommation d'énergie quelle
consommation d'énergie prendre de
l'énergie pour faire ce pacte de
responsabilité que son cice après
reprendre de l'énergie pour supprimer le
cic et en faire une diminution de
charges quel temps perdu
que d'énergie pour rien dépenser nous
verrons là aussi comment le cic se sera
transformé en baisse de 2 charge quant
au contrat de travail lui même
il ya eu des propositions du président
de la république de monsieur hollande
nous verrons au fond comment elles
seront ajustés donc j'ai parlé du temps
de travail
on peut évoquer aussi tout ce qui
concerne le dialogue social je remarque
que là-dessus il n'y a pas d'évolution
et se situe d'ailleurs presque en
opposition ce que nous avons déjà dit
sur au fond l'idée que à un moment donné
la démocratie politique va plus loin que
la démocratie sociale qu'il faut corps
intermédiaires c'est très important
sauf qu'à un moment donné on n'a pas
besoin d'intermédiation avec les
français il faut au contraire être dans
la décision immédiate nous verrons ce
que le président dira dans les textes
qui viendront sur le contrat de travail
nous sommes favorables à l'idée que la
négociation collective s'impose au
contrat de travail
nous sommes favorables est-ce que les
motifs de rupture du contrat de travail
soient clairement identifiés dans le
contrat de travail lui même nous sommes
favorables à limiter le risque pour
l'entreprise notamment devant les
prud'hommes de l'indemnisation du
licenciement nous disons depuis
longtemps nous l'avons tellement dit que
nous l'avons même écrit dans une
convention sur le marché et sur le code
du travail
ouvrez expliqueront tout ça au moment où
le débat viendra
voilà c'est un plan d'urgence
l'urgence elle est déjà elle a déjà
sonné depuis depuis longtemps tout ça
vient bien tard vous font presque un
plan d'urgence pour le gouvernement lui
même plus que pour l'emploi on est là
avec des intentions politiques
extrêmement marqué la france décroche je
ne sais pas si ce plan est en capacité
de répondre à ce décrochage en tout cas
nous ne le pensons pas nous verrons au
moment de son application et surtout de
sa discussion dans des textes différents
à l'assemblée nationale et au sénat ce
qu'il en sera on peut pas mentir sur les
500 milles je pense que c'est quelque
chose d'assez graves pour le reste
mais là dessus il ya un mensonge
vraiment éhontée on ne peut pas on ne
peut pas malheureusement former 500
mille personnes
en plus on ne peut pas les formes et
puisque les emplois ne sont pas là
derrière il ya risque de décélération de
la désespérance mais semble-t-il qui est
extrêmement important à chaud ce que
nous pouvons dire
certainement oublié beaucoup de choses
mais si vous avez deux trois questions
j'y répondra avec plaisir